and Clayton Bigsby black white
supremacist ventured out into an
unsuspecting world sir you're a friend
why not tell him he's african-american
listen man it's too important to the
movement well tell em he's black you
probably kill yourself just to be one
less nigger around his commitment is
that deep I'm overwhelmed by the irony
we don't like your kind around here you
better get out of here for some bad come
on clay crew we gotta go oh thanks
there's a nigger
laughs power
the confusion did not end there
why'd you yell about eternity pal
letters nightly stack will they burn in
there
sniggers the anticipation was at a fever
pitch as we arrived at mr. Bigsby's book
signing the next president of the United
State
all right days for time to show these
people who have powers all the back -
you better put your hood on Clayton all
right I want to I'm gonna hide your
identity be safer
you know in case some radical in
sympathies of the cause wants to shoot
you who made us proud to be why Clayton
Bigsby
[Applause]
mainly negress Marco's in war the
al-qaeda
well we're still losing the world is the
answer during age of eternity who was a
target as well let's talk about Chinese
people with their kung Fu's oh that
silly cheng chang chong town I can't
understand you go back to your country
why Papa mr. Bigley was also critical of
the entertainment industry you may share
some round with whale politicians
weren't spared are there black power
holding pal carnal Angus rides howling
this price sounds like a Mexican dish
maybe we should put her on a plate and
sit into Mexico so the next is later
[Applause]
we want to see your face
[Music]
[Applause]
there is cookie and punch forest enjoy
and we can make talk about whap
Brotherhood thank y'all for coming by
power mr. Bigsby was not harmed that
night
but irreparable damage has been done to
his reputation and in many ways the
white power movement we're told that in
the last few weeks he has accepted the
fact that he is a black man and three
days ago he filed for divorce from his
wife when we asked why after 19 years of
marriage he responded because she's a
nigger lover I'm Kent Wallace
[Applause]
funding for frontline provided by the
Triplett foundation for peace and
understanding loving black people one at
a time